hello folks and welcome back to game
sports coverage of the electronic triple
2016 myself and Michael are joined by
mr. Timothy what's your middle name [ __ ]
no middle name John Timothy J Schafer
the president I've never been introduced
little name before there you go there
everyone knows I'm now they're going to
steal your identity give up my social I
know yeah we can tell you where you live
as well you guys on the same bus road
right hmm be careful yeah yeah yeah yeah
good to have you here as ever having me
on your lovely couch a pleasure with
Andy I know do you want one of our air
heads as i leave you can this this whole
set is actually sponsored by airheads
would you like one you're welcome for
letting you yeah thank you so much is
that you're right we don't even do to
our plugs Tim Schafer will come on and
do it for you that big airhead you have
Siri three going so far it's great it's
great it's awesome we've been showing
the shearling I'm not just off like for
just four things at least but I also
seen a lot of cool games and press
conferences were exciting and yeah
laughing what have you got to play
yourself walking around and play there's
a really game bound as a VR version of
bound in the VR section of the sony
booth and always like to see below come
a long way yes we have Mason on tomorrow
I think to the inside and I think I'm up
with a third prepositional phrase that's
right bub next to okc was pretty good
right no really good waiting on to ever
play inside the size about that yeah a
pretty soon and we are not here to talk
about inside we're here to talk about
slightly gods in the rhombus of ruin
your virtual reality experiment you guys
have always been doing this been like
messing with the tech you made some of
the most like interesting games on
connect yeah what's it like been working
in virtual reality would you like to try
out new stuff and virtual reality is
that it's kind of natural for us because
we always like to make worlds then pull
you in it make you want to feel like
you're in a space this is transformative
your teleport into a different world and
VR just pops you right into that and
it's it's kind of intense because um you
know you can tell that it looks nice
when you look at the film but until you
put on the goggles you're in the world
like right now all those different
figments you're seeing you recognize
from the first game think they're all at
different depths
so it really feels like you're in this
3d space all around you full mental
figments right doesn't sort of come
across a lot of this stuff on the
screens and so for folks who folks who
have fights like a nuts are you playing
as either way it works yeah yeah like
where what is the stories is filling in
between one and two is that because it
tells the mission of the rescue of
Truman's annatto which is he's the grand
head of the psycho nuts and the father
of your girlfriend and if you play the
first game or if you haven't it still
works but you you enter the first game
becoming a psycho not saving the day and
then you hear about Truman getting
kidnapped in you all jump into a jet and
fly off to save them that's it cut roll
credits and this game picks up right
after that now you're in the jet and
you're trying to find Germans anoto and
rescue him but first you have a little
tutorial where you get to relearn some
of your second abilities but now in a
virtual space you guys threat years have
had to go back to the sort of you've
done you know remasters of somebody roll
the games and had to like take these
characters that looked you know a
certain way at a certain era and update
them I mean the same thing is happening
here we have these crazy super detailed
3d versions of characters from the old
psychonauts game at what's really look
like in my head the whole time right now
they look more like that finally
realized finally realized and lucious
lucious 3d this is our first game in
unreal forest so right so use all the
bells and whistles of that engine and
and he's also kind of a warming up of
that world the second letter which was
shipped ten years ago right so don't
forget to call it but the actors some of
them he retired and we're like hey come
back and do this game and you know kind
of hoping their voices we're still still
there sound great that's how amazing so
all the character Sasha I'm Mia and Lily
and the coach are all there and it was
fun to be back in the studio recording
with them and a great way to get ready
for a second thoughts too as well so
what's the moment-to-moment action of
the rhombus a room like what are you
what are you doing what type of your
game experience we talking about it it
is a kind of dementia game kind of a
puzzling game were in not platforming we
really wanted you to be comfortable
which means you know very we're pretty
conservative with our motion where
you're mostly in a chair but you're
you're psychic so it's a perfect fit for
VR like I could levitate that bowl of
air head brain Kenny and I could burn it
which you would never do no man
confection no you can use
psychic abilities to move objects with
your brain telekinesis to rotate like
look at them and then throw them away or
burn them or or put them in the right
place to solve the puzzle but then you
also use clairvoyance which allows you
to is it like I time that looked arrived
at a clairvoyant on their wines and you
can which means you can see the world
through someone else's eyes so I could
jump into your head and see myself I'm
looking back on myself like I look over
there and see someone on the camera and
I can jump into their head and I can
look out the window and see someone jump
there and so that's how we can avegant
the world instead of just teleporting to
a spot on the floor you're going to
another brain which means you also
seeing how that person sees the world
and that can be sometimes slightly
different kids right yeah and did this
stuff get was this at all connected to
the fig funding of looks like an art
store is just like Sam's or things rom
mr. Bruin is funded by sudden or pounds
okay honey and this was it's on the
PlayStation VR and second of two is
funded by our crowdfunding campaign yeah
was I call the fig because of the fig i
think i was part of the idea that the
hotel okay and I heard somebody mention
that to me a couple days ago I was like
ah yeah that makes sense although
hopefully your fate will be but is the
figuring torn down or getting real young
as they took the name away now the
camera operators that's why I'm closed
down before I know that's not your key
remodeled remodeled okay made uh more
beautiful and luscious just like
sacrifice there you go yeah and so
what's how long is this experience we
don't want to hold off till we finish it
and time it out but write it this is
just an introductory area it's kind of
small confined the other areas are
bigger and there's more of them and
you're solving actual puzzles it's not
just like it's not just like a demo or
like a room that you play with it's a
real story and adventure and has a
narrative you go into a mental world and
the whole game just like you do in
second ops and so it's a real full-on
game as I say do they yeah they all say
it's a long game while we're talking
like that good huh Michael just Joe kill
have you played rhombus arun a lot of VR
games this week why he not played it ah
clémence I was gonna signed it I didn't
make my way over there I don't have an
excuse i'll play it I've got a couple
days left we had a yeah Barry put you on
the spot like I could have lied I said
it yeah I played the part where in the
jet and you're looking around
and then he like a squirrel on the roof
yet yeah that's a squirrel summer camp
is this coming ash for sort of launched
a PlayStation VR is that around yeah aim
for the end of the year okay what's it
like been like I guess you know with kit
with Kinect and all the games you sort
of developed for that I imagine you were
doing a lot of bringing in friends and
family to sort of figure it out and then
demo is testing it yeah yeah yeah I mean
you know kick party was a great game the
whole family could play it you have had
people like my daughter's play this
although i think they say in US was a
little kids play right she likes it so
what they say if you are yeah it kills
him instantly I'm not a psycho not like
yeah don't the kid should sometimes kids
can play second half it's totally kid
family yes so what's up in like I guess
trying to develop with this new type of
technology that so many people are
having like a little bit of trouble
trying to get folks that comfortable
with it and who might have teach them to
sort of I guess there's the language of
virtual reality what's up in like well I
mean it's really exciting to be at the
beginning of something and everyone's
like even the biggest players in the
games industry are like what is a VR
game what is it how do you move you know
like and everybody you know the smartest
views ministry or transfer got this
problem and you know we think we have a
good solution there are psychic context
lets us give toilet paper to the player
perfect yeah but um the second car is I
think a fit perfectly well with VR I
just spoiler for one of the major so now
you never sleep sometime you complete
that one but we're really sensitive to
I'm the first person to get sick if
anything goes wrong right you're so
we're gonna make there's going to be
nothing in this game that ever makes you
sick yeah I'm the best canary in a coal
mine for that kind of so so it's like
it's a great time to be doing stuff
because everything is so new and but
also it's really intense like you it's
hard to explain unless you put on the
goggles what it's like to stare in the
face of another character right and
their eyes are looking at you and then
you know the other game characters look
at the screen and stuff but that they're
really looking at you and it's really
it's really like it must be like
enjoyable as a designer especially
considering you worked so much in a in
genre that you sort of helped popularize
very much so part of all that team at
Lucas and then sort of like maybe it was
or wasn't but so it became like a known
quantity like people thought they knew
what adventure games were so then you're
probably doing a lot of like extra work
to try and like usurp expectations or is
here it's like almost like you've got a
blank slate well who people don't really
know I just answered your question for
you haven't oh yeah what he said that's
true we uh yeah we're gonna possibly add
to that except for how delicious
airheads are but I get paid every time I
know now I certainly don't say you
shouldn't I think you made up for a
magnet that you for Danny forgot sure
yeah yeah so much Russia that if I
mentioned a different candy right now
only four times would it be would it be
bad if I mentioned a different game Oh
psychonauts game can I talk about
seconds to or rhombus Aroon or head
Lander you talk about head Lander p1 or
full throttle okay I've given you a lot
of options can I talk briefly about a
game you didn't make fine i might fall
asleep you know I gonna ask you about
good no have you played uncharted 4 yeah
yeah you have i'm at the variant don't
spoil it I don't spoil it eat above in
like one of the final tunnels okay just
sayin hire a tunnel and then writing
some I think you're gonna talk about
some pirates so familiar yes it appeared
in it can I just ask you were you
involved in those conversations no we're
not I mean um I mean I don't know if
they called Ron or not right so we're
talking about that um know what I heard
is Alan spoil if everybody but they
would have spoiled it for me really yeah
that sucks Neil druckmann sent me at
codys I can't play a game now I was like
okay okay I'm getting to it but then the
day it came out people like have you
seen this photo and there's like a
there's an easter egg is a fun easter
egg that references refers to a game
that i had work done but um it's a
really funny story but they had spoiled
it but i didn't realize the depth of it
like he keeps going i know there are
some other references to like that's the
second biggest yeah x i have ever seen
which is almost like oh with a monkey
and they're always they're always
references that are fun and I could he
was like yeah we're just gonna get in
there like mega that's for
actual permission I really like this
from an amazing well I feel like I'm
scared of saying with these names
because okay you're behind us but rice
the powers that be I got official
permission from the powers of me I'm
what cats happening to me when I was
playing it was then I felt like I was
projecting like I kept seeing like is it
me monkey island is in it like no you
said the word now okay there was there
was there was one one part where there's
somebody with a telescope sitting at the
end of that is that what is that too I
was like is that a reference or just
that right yeah is that yeah so I guess
but I fast Neil druckmann yeah that one
goes like but I think it's done in a way
that if you're you don't know anything
about that game it was just fine yeah he
does look younger than all the other
pirates hey could we talk about
Psychonauts 2 as well I'd rather have an
uncharted the whole time I talk about
because I want to help those guys out
there stop buying rice you know did you
guys know doing talks about him there's
give a chance I'm psychonauts is also
good right well how's fig gone that was
a crazy sort of experiment yeah it was a
we wanted a crowd fund this game but
also you feel a little strange with
crowdfunding sometimes you take bunch of
money like what if your game is a huge
huge hit right and you get rich and
thanks to the backers and you get a
t-shirt and that's cool but it's nice to
be able to say like if you know if this
game does really well you're gonna share
we're gonna share and that's what fig is
all about you can actually share in the
profits for the game and so it did
better than any crowdfunding we've ever
done before rice we made almost four
million dollars of that and and now
we're gonna make this game this awesome
game is that where the impetus came from
that it sort of felt like the
relationship there you know I would we
kind of like I guess we know in
kickstarter and all of these things
started came off we didn't really
understand what we wanted out of creb
funny but I i guess you as a creator and
somebody asking for money didn't really
understand what you wanted out of it
either did it was it just kind of like a
moral thing we thought like maybe this
is it it was the one just like
uncomfortable part of it reader I for
the first thing to happen it was more
just like we're trying to this thing we
help us and everyone I think felt really
good about that yeah but to have it be a
repeatable thing like this isn't just a
stunt this isn't just like a novelty
we're going to talk about a whole new
way to fun games forever then it has to
be more not
about goodwill but also about like
fairness and and and you know you can't
just go off shucks we need help again
over and over again and then just keep
keeping all that money and you have to
say like this is the deal if you help us
you get to share the profits as fair and
repeatable and I think it's just a whole
new way for games get funded in the
future I'm has work on so I cannot still
coming along it's awesome we have Zach
McClendon as early designer the leaders
in around bioshock 2 and um really smart
looking taking a really deep look at all
the mechanics in the first game because
the first game is you know you know it
had a crazy story and crazy inventive
like things that happened all these
mental worlds you never know what's
gonna happen in the game and we really
want to go and look at all the
collectibles and all the psychic powers
and really tune them to be just amazing
in the second game and also like bring
back some of the old second power the
people like but also add some new ones
and new twists to it is there a pressure
to make this for you know for a new
crowd as well like so I cannot always
seem like one of those franchises that
you know have like an incredibly you
know passionate sort of group of people
later but you know I'm guessing you
shifted rented people publishers and
they weren't you know maybe it's
confident that the without that like
mass appeal yeah yeah something happened
thought to a third person stylistic
brightly colored humorous platformers
there was like a period where like oh
that was a million of them like giant
citizen kabuto second let's was in there
yeah with like you know ratchet and
jacket rides games and and then it
seemed like people are like you know
kids want something edgier darker more
brutal you know a lot of and they didn't
like let's see where we can take games
and how gritty and dark we can make them
and I feel like we hit that I feel like
we've definitely made games are as
brutal and ready as people want I think
and I like okay now I'd like to have
some brightly colored shoes and and
it'll be a happy character like I think
I think there's a does this room to go
back to games that are funny and games
him stylized art and aren't all just
brown and then bloody and it's been
toned down the next stabs of it yeah and
I mean clearly it's working good would
say fifty percent as much Nick next
abscess yeah i mean this honors even
ride a lot of them yeah
they've got the corner market on Meg's
neck stabbing I think right now psy
class 2 is a competitor though uh
psychic next steps okay yeah you go into
people's minds maybe through the neck a
couple times right yeah yeah get like
zoo in ourselves yeah oh that's all
right yes here's an idea for you yeah so
wait how do we get started at all the
next ads anyway I think people are
underserved in that area I think people
would like to have an option like you
see with like banjo kazooie spiritual
side uh sir yeah yeah ukulele will have
them on the show you Ailee tell ya yeah
great to have you on rhombus ruin airs
later this year yeah and what about
Slyke wants to so that's two you look
for updates we just put out the fig
update show some progress check your
inbox yeah yeah check your bulletin
board what about a blunder when we see
that head ladder is command house the
actual date very soon very very soon I
think I'm not allowed to say the date
because of weird things I'm very soon
and it's awesome and lender I final
question what's your favorite candy I
want to get you guys in trouble not I've
always enjoyed alphas Ella okay for was
enough to say for pleasure i go to a
blessed luck we look forward to seeing
sorry chef of so i can also in the next
going once thank you so much for
watching everyone livestream we have one
more we actually were going to have a
little chinwag about yeah sorry mike and
i missed your favorite face about what
our favorite games here at e3 2016 but
actually we managed to get the god of
war folks to come in and talk about that
so stick around we'll be back in just a
second we've got a board